you went to the Emmys and and everybody
goes to the Emmys they just put on their
tux and they go especially the guys and
it's yeah boring okay agreed and you
every year have tried to do something
interesting a bunch of years ago I think
we'll check out this still right here
you went as Freddy Krueger okay well
looks like a dressed-up Freddy Krueger
so it's not the complete outfit the tie
is like a sweater and then just the hand
right so it's a formal Freddy Krueger
and then I don't know if this was last
year I think you went is Frankenstein
and you just put just the bolts just the
Bulls just the boats and then my suit
was a little short like I had the
sleeves come up like this and the pants
were high these are really subtle
monsters you're doing yes subtle
monsters subtle these are monsters with
just a little like look what you did
this year this intrigued me this is the
subtlest
subtle Dracula and the it's you know
he's like he has a medallion so this is
the tie it's just implied there yeah
yeah these are the least frightening
monsters I've ever seen is there is
these are monsters that you know they're
hanging out you see them at the mall and
they're fine yes they're at an event
they don't want to you know draw too
much attention they're just there to say
hello
you